i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning if someone has actually never
seen
any work you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
i would probably have to go with
spider-man you know there's a big body
of work there there's three there's six
films that you can go and watch that i
think are really fun and exciting i mean
that's probably what i would go for
spider-man yeah i would probably say uh
one one of the uh true stories maybe
lone survivor or
you know uh perfect storm joe bell the
fighter some what something along those
lines
is one of my favorite movies i love that
movie so much thank you buddy and i
actually use the soundtrack from that
movie if i need to get emotional in a
scene really
yeah there's it's called like the mighty
rio grande or something and it plays
throughout the beginning in the end
i use that if i need to cry i love that
scene i love that film mate it's
brilliant oh nice thank you i i uh thank
you for sharing that tom um
that's a really cool that's actually
really cool um mark you've been attached
to or you were attached to the david
o'russell version of uncharted back in
2010 what do you think it is about this
material that's taken so long to get to
the screen
you know it's one of those obviously
getting it right um the tone
introduction to that world uh you know
it's 40 million games sold it's
obviously beloved by by its fans and so
you've got to get it right and i think
you know it's so cinematic anyway that
it's a must make for a film it's just a
matter of getting it right you know you
really got to nail it and i think the
smartest thing to do would kind of start
out where we did and watching tom as
nate come into his own and then i think
from there you know the uh the
opportunities are endless
tom when you work with mark does it mean
you get a wahlburgers gift card for life
no
i was gonna say yes hang on a minute
i uh
admittedly have never had a wool burgers
but i will do and i said i will do i
just haven't had the time but i'm gonna
i'm gonna have one we're gonna hold you
to that don't worry yeah i'll let you
know the chicken sandwiches there are
pretty good um just just throwing that
out there uh yeah um so uh
why did you when did where did that come
from mate
what what burgers burgers like what
inspired you to set up a burger company
oh i i had no interest in doing my
brother is a is a really really good
chef and he's had massive success he's
been head chefs at many different
restaurants and then he went on to open
a restaurant named after my mom and then
he wanted to do a burger chain and me
being the entrepreneur that i am i said
okay we're going to do it but we're
going to
open a lot of them so we now have 100
stores and we're going probably
hopefully in the next two years to 400
stores
wow yeah yeah mark doesn't mark doesn't
mess around tom i have to i have to ask
you there is a crazy action set piece in
this movie which is the cargo plane
sequence and you've obviously worked on
many action scenes before how did that
sequence compare to some of the marvel
stuff you've done playing spider-man was
it just a completely different beast uh
can you sort of talk about it
yeah i mean naturally it was very
different to creating a spider-man
action sequence spider-man being a
superhero being able to do things that
humans can't do we have a creative
license to kind of lean on you know the
resource of cgi whereas with uncharted
play nathan drake everything is you know
we're doing everything we can to ground
it in reality so it meant that most of
what we had to do had to be done
practically now i'm not saying we
actually hung out in the back of an
airplane you know there are elements of
movie making involved tom cruise tom
cruise would have
tom cruise would have that's true that's
true but listen
so it's a tough it's a tough name to
carry
it's a tough name to carry mate but yeah
so we you know we worked hard and we we
we put blood sweat and tears into that
sequence it was tough it was tough i
wasn't crying mark was because he
he wanted to be involved yeah no i was i
was happy to be in the helicopter bar
the greatest thing ever was when i was
like and we had
discussions and thankfully tom supported
me in this that i was like sully was
just such a guy that you know if you
weren't doing the right thing he had to
always it was always about
self-preservation so i told him once put
that put the parachute on he said no so
i was like okay i'm just going to pull
mine and go. and everybody was like oh
it seems a little bit cold but you
didn't want to give away the fact that
sally was going to you know really
sacrificed everything to support nate
and uh and tom was really understanding
of that i wanted to get off that plane
as quickly as i could before all
the heavy lifting started
my last my last thing for you guys uh
this game has a ton of fans a ton of
people have played this game what are
you most excited for fans of the game to
actually see in the movie i think for me
i'm excited for them to see uh
a storyline that they had to before
imagine you know we're telling we're
telling the the origin story of these
characters that people know and love
around the world you know mark said sold
40 million copies so we have a huge
audience to try and impress and i i'm
delighted to say that i really think
that we've pulled off what everyone is
hoping we have
but this origin story i think is going
to be really appealing to all the fans
of the games
yeah not obviously not everybody who's a
big fan of the game has seen it but
certainly some of the
the kind of most vocal have seen it and
getting their stamp of approval was was
amazing and then also
because the the game is so cinematic it
really allows for everybody to enjoy
this movie you don't have to have ever
played the game to to go and enjoy it's
like indiana jones or you know romancing
the stone this is a big fun
movie and you haven't seen one in quite
a while so we're excited
uh thank you both so much for talking
with me i hope it's a huge hit i wish
you guys nothing but the best thank you
buddy good to see you as always